In the fall of 1589,
the town of Bedburg, Germany,
held a highly publicized trial.
Peter Stubbe was accused
of several gruesome crimes,
including murder, assault,
and cannibalism.
But perhaps the most sinister accusation
of them all,
was of being a werewolf.
In his confession, Peter claimed that
the devil had given him a magic girdle,
which allowed him to transform into a wolf
and perform his horrific acts.
Stories of werewolves existed well before
this trial and continue to live on today.
They’re especially prominent
in European literature and folklore,
and often found in cultures where the wolf
is the largest natural predator.
Over the years, the image of the werewolf
has continuously evolved,
often reflecting the fears and prejudices
of that time.
In early literature, werewolves were
sometimes painted as sympathetic figures:
victims of curses who longed to return
to their human form.
In the story of Gilgamesh,
one of the earliest written accounts of
werewolves from over 4.000 years ago,
a shepherd falls in love
with the goddess of love, Ishtar,
who transforms him into a wolf
when she grows tired of his affection.
In this and several other
stories that followed,
werewolves were often men who had fallen
prey to deceitful, alluring women.
In the medieval story of “Bisclavret,”
a knight is trapped in wolf form
by the cunning of his wife,
who leaves him to elope with another man.
Other early stories explored fears
about the darker side of human nature,
including taboos such as
cannibalism and murder.
In ancient Greek mythology,
King Lycaon was transformed
into a wolf by Zeus,
after he attempted to trick the god
into eating human flesh.
As Catholicism spread throughout Europe,
werewolves became increasingly linked
to magic, sorcery, and pagan belief.
By the 16th century, many people struggled
separating werewolf fiction from fact.
Political, economic,
and religious upheavals
gave rise to the infamous
European witch trials.
And while witches were the main
targets, in some areas,
alleged werewolves like Peter Stubbe
were also tried and executed.
Today, some historians view the trials
as driven by a fear of outsiders,
as well as society's early attempts
to understand brutal crimes.
While public belief in werewolves
died down by the 17th century
as medicine and psychology advanced,
the myth would re-emerge in literature.
By the Victorian period,
werewolves had transformed again,
often embodying fears of moral
and psychological decay.
In George Reynolds’s
“Wagner the Wehrwolf,”
the protagonist makes a pact with the
devil to achieve eternal youth.
But in return, he transforms
into a violent howling wolf
at the end of every month.
By the mid-20th century,
werewolves found a new home to haunt—
the silver screen.
Here, the werewolf began to take
its modern form.
For example, the idea that the curse
could be transmitted through bites
and triggered by a full moon
was first popularized with the
1935 film “Werewolf of London.”
Produced in the United States,
the film identifies the werewolf infection
as originating from the east—
specifically Tibet.
This mirrored xenophobic fears
of the time—
that East Asian immigrants
into North America and Europe
threatened the stability and power
of the west.
Werewolf hunters adopted silver
as their weapon of choice
after its use in 1941′s “The Wolf Man.”
Written by Jewish writer Curt Siodmak,
the film is viewed by many scholars
as an allegory for Nazi brutality.
In the film, a pentagram appears on the
palm of the werewolf’s next victim,
which is thought to allude to the
compulsory Star of David badges
found in Europe during the 1930 and 40s.
Since the 1950s, cinematic werewolves have
frequently infected
a new group of victims:
the teenager.
Here, werewolves are often symbols
of male aggression
and the uncertainty of adolescence.
By the end of the century,
some films began to use
the beastly transformation
to explore themes of puberty,
occasionally with a distinctly
feminist perspective.
Yet, like all great monsters,
the werewolf lives on,
and will continue changing to fit
its future audience’s needs.
But, for the time being, it may
be best to stock up on silver,
keep to the road, and beware the moon.